[Music]
all right up next is rachel from kansas
city
hey rachel love your name welcome to the
show
hi rachel and dr john how are you guys
we're doing great sure would have been
better if you were named john but go
ahead
just kidding go ahead this is my parents
second choice
awesome how can we help
well i was hoping you guys could help me
learn some tools to stay motivated and
on track when completing the baby steps
um i'm in baby step number two i haven't
gotten very far i've only paid off a
couple small debts i have my thousand
dollar emergency fund but it seems like
every time i save up a little bit of
money to pay or to start paying off
another debt i somehow convince myself
that i need something so i go out i
spend my money and then i come home and
i'm completely ashamed of myself scold
myself a little bit and then i move on
and say i'll do better next time and
then next time comes i just do it all
over again um
and my i have three little girls at home
my oldest is about to turn 15 this month
and it got me thinking like oh my gosh
she's going to be driving in the year i
really need to get my crap together
because i need to set a better example
for them and just hoping that you guys
can help me get on track and stay on
track
so i was doing a practicum
for my one of the cool things about
going back to school when i was as an
old guy is i had to do a practicum again
i had to be an intern again
and i was doing my internship with this
guy named dr michael gomez a brilliant
child psychologist and we were working
with traumatized kids
and he was about 10 maybe 15 years
younger than me he's just so savant
and we were walking out of a room one
day when we were working with the little
child who was saying some really
abhorrent things like some really rough
things about women and i happen to have
a little boy at the time
and i was would ask questions that were
cloaked um
psychology questions really i was just
asking like this brilliant person how
can i be a better dad right
and so we were walking from one room to
another and i said
well what do you tell a little boy
so that he'll respect women when he
grows up
and he he was on to me really fast and
dr gomez said this and it has stuck with
me forever he said i don't know you can
tell whatever you want to
but if you want to respect women just
know he's watching everything you do
so if you want him to respect women um
treat your wife right and then he just
walked into the next room and i was like
oh no and then he popped back out a
minute later he's like and make sure you
take care of the waitress and tip i mean
he just started rattling all these
things off and so here's what i'm
telling you
quote unquote getting your crap together
or i need to start setting a good
example you've got 15 years that your
daughter has absorbed
you all of it how you respond to
challenges what you do when you get
frustrated it sounds like you spend when
you're feeling less than or when you're
feeling frustrated or whatever
yeah what we need to do now is have a
direct hard conversation with your 15
year old that says i've modeled x
and from this point forward i'm going to
start doing different i just had one of
these with my son
about like i'm just a kind of a chaotic
hurricane of a mess when it comes to
just throwing stuff around
and i had a set i sat down with him and
said i've modeled for you
uh what poor organizational skills look
like and i'm making a change and you're
going to be uncomfortable during this
change because it's going to disrupt the
way we do life
but i haven't i've let you down as your
dad we just had this conversation a few
weeks ago
and then you've got to make some really
tactical shifts in how you respond and
do your life
okay i is that fair
that is fair i was going through him
playing through it and thinking like
what is he going to say what are they
going to say to me and that did not pop
up
i am glad that you surprised me
absolutely yeah and i think there's
something to rachel about having that
cover which i love that john said that
because she's 15. she i mean she's 15 so
she's 15 but she's also 15. like she she
has her head on her yeah she knows
what's going on
and there's a level of humility too as a
parent to sit down and just kind of say
out loud like man
i hate that i did that and i hate that
this is you know x y and z that i know
that this is this is my knee-jerk
behavior and this is what you've seen in
your life and i want to do better having
a parent with that level of humility
there's something that could even change
in y'all's relationship rachel with you
and your daughter like there's just
something beautiful that can happen
because you kind of open that door to be
like i'm human too i'm human too and i
mess up and presenting that to her is is
amazing and then what john said in
another call a few segments ago
and then actually doing the action
changing your environment putting
putting yourself in other situations
where you're not
taking the money you know tactically and
and going and shopping with it but
versus paying off the debt like all that
you know can get fixed but that um yeah
foundation will just shift in your head
of knowing that yeah more is coughed and
taught she's she is going to be watching
all of your kids are going to be
watching you
and you can say whatever you want but
those actions it's huge that's it
why do you um why do you spend
um i i really feel like my emotions
drive my spending so like when i'm happy
i guess i want to continue the good time
right and be happier and then when i'm
upset or
mad or stressed out i feel like shopping
might make me happy going to spend money
um
i think it's very emotionally driven
so what are some things you could do
today
that would put some hurdles between you
your emotional self and your acting self
in counseling we call it the gap between
stimulus and response
i feel this need to keep this thing
going
but i know that i got to get up at 6 a.m
and go to work tomorrow i'm gonna have
to pay this credit card bill in 28 days
what are some things you could do right
now and you're gonna help millions of
people by just rattling off one or two
that you could put in between you your
feeling and that action
maybe i could
um i set a rule for myself saying no if
i feel like no rules no rules
too easy
cancel amazon prime today for 30 days
okay
take your debit card out of your wallet
okay
take it out oh it sounds good just don't
carry it with you
unless you're going to a grocery store
and then you're coming home
make it to where i will have to go ask
somebody to borrow money in a bar to
keep this thing going right or i'm gonna
have to reach across the pedal tavern
and ask whoever if i can borrow some
money right whatever it is you're doing
put some obstacles in front of you and
then bring your daughters along with you
create a budget and every week sit down
with your daughters um
is dad around
um i i'm remarried so there's that dad
lives in the home okay so bring make it
a family affair we're all in on this and
you're gonna have 15 year olds that
can't wait to point out mom's flaws
and so like she's going to be do we have
enough but is this in the budget is this
in the budget right so you're going to
bring everybody along but what you're
doing is you're creating a hurdle of
accountability you have a lot of eyes
you're gonna invite a lot of eyes to be
watching your actions okay
take some steps i gotta reach out and
call i've done this i gave my wife my
debit card for a season because i was
out of control and i had to call my wife
as though she was my mommy and at
because i had to learn to do things
differently
right and it was the long-term play was
much more important than my little
precious ego
and my little precious feelings and
emotions and
in those moments
is that fair okay
that's fair i'm glad you guys brought
the humility piece into it i think
that's a huge problem for me as well i
feel like i always
i just want my kids to think that you
know they have everything that they need
mommy will get them whatever they want
yeah and
i guess
having that conversation with them and
being like well that's just not the way
it works yeah and rachel
one of the best definitions of humility
i've heard is that humility is not
thinking less of yourself but it's
thinking of yourself less so you've been
thinking less of yourself when you've
messed up and you're beating yourself up
so humility is not i'm just terrible i
screwed up i mean there's a level of
just accountability of yeah here's what
really has happened factually in my life
and the choices i've made and i have to
deal with those but true humility is
thinking less of yourself and that's
what you're doing you're wanting to get
out of debt you're wanting to create a
better life for your girls you told us
that on the call and so demonstrating
that humility that your life it is less
about me and it is more about serving my
family and this is what this that's
gonna be the motivation that i'm taking
as i'm making these new changes so hang
on the line rachel uh we are gonna give
you
financial peace university and we're
gonna give you every dollar app for a
year we're gonna give you the whole
shebang for you to start with your kids
and you're gonna work you're gonna let
them watch the videos with you y'all
gonna go through this thing together and
you are gonna teach them what humility
looks like and that's gonna be a gift
that's gonna be a legacy changer